[Musique]
où
je m'appelle colette dès lors j'ai 53
ans et je suis consultante
administrative principalement dans le
domaine foncier
[Musique]
et dès les gens c'est ce que j'aime le
plus au monde
voilà ça fait partie de mon caractère
des valeurs de la vie beaucoup de
personnes se trouvent confrontés à des
situations difficiles
ils ne savent pas où s'orienter ils
savent pas vers qui aller ils sont
totalement perdus
toutes les personnes qui sont dans un
besoin foncier dans un projet foncier
papa maman qui sont propriétaires qui
veulent pas d une donation à leurs
enfants parents décédés donc drame
psychologique on est déstabilisé
désorientés on sait pas comment faire
et ben moi avec plaisir je souhaite
accompagner saison là dans ces moments
difficiles de la vie et a déjà dans les
familles malheureusement très souvent
des conflits
moi je suis là j'ai aussi un rôle de
médiatrice jeu construit des ponts entre
les gens
[Musique]
pourquoi engagements parce que quand
vous avez lancé dans l'histoire d'une
famille quand
vous demandez à une famille qui
s'approche de vous et qui a besoin de
vos services de vous témoigner de la
confiance se dire c'est pas une petite
affaire s'est d'emblée créer un climat
de confiance et montrer à votre client
qu' à travers ce débat de confiance ne
démarrons un travail ensemble et nous
irons jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
que la population réunionnaise qui ne me
connaît pas encore puisse me solliciter
pour que j'ai les moyens d'aider encore
plus de gens je suis capable et j'en ai
envie
[Musique]